so two years ago on October 17th a group
of privileged Villanova students
embarked upon a journey like never
before enrolling into a social justice
documentary class founded by the amazing
Hezekiah Lewis some of us did not know
we were going to Africa especially Ghana
shoutout Caleb abruptly we found
ourselves on set in Ghana filming
footage for a story we had only
partially outlined it took many intense
discussions many possible story lines
and lots of research to come to this
thought-provoking documentary Sankofa
sang Cole for literally means go back
and fetch it you need to go back to your
past in order to understand the present
african-american history did not start
with slavery it interrupted it our film
addresses the loss of African identity
and black males in both Ghana and Africa
in our film we talk about the loss of
African identity in the black male and
how that paralleled disconnect has been
a direct negative result of colonialism
and slavery on behalf of the whole
riptide pictures team we would like to
thank first and foremost God's Way
Anderson and Marquis grant who are
principal characters for allowing us
into their lives and sharing their
stories we would also like to thank our
academic experts Chi Chi a coma and
Amar'e Johnson for giving us helpful
in-store achill insight the stories of
God's Way and marquees represent those
of millions around the world who are
dealing with a historical disconnect
from modes of slavery and colonialism
thank you to the Academy for this
incredible honor to the North family and
the Waterhouse foundation thank you for
your generous donations and your
continued support throughout our process
a huge thank you to father Peter Donahue
and Dean Adele Linda Mayer from
Villanova University for your passion
and willingness to provide resources to
ensure that Sankofa would be seen by
everyone to our professors our mentor
Hezekiah Lewis all we can say is we're
all the good phase we are endlessly
grateful for you when we were in the lab
and so four or five in the morning you
were there with us when we needed
guidance or advice you were there for
all of us through your sacrifice and
dedication this program and storytelling
we are able to share some Coffield on
numerous platforms you gave us the
freedom and responsibility to have
complete say over our phone giving us
the space and confidence to make Sanko
fho thank you for providing student
opportunity on campus for creativity
passion and social justice for pushing
us to make a film that is raw and real
for challenging us in our own personal
and team growth Sankofa would not be
what it is today without you or your
family support especially your wife
leash leash we love you to our families
and friends we are so sorry we all
disappeared for like a year to make this
film there are many late nights many
missed classes and we don't encourage
that missed calls and missed events fire
phone you are all you all were and
continue to be our support system thank
you for all you do we love you from the
bottom of our hearts and I'm almost done
guys so Coco will always be about the
art of storytelling using the art of
film to break down cultural barriers
challenge our own preconceived notions
of the world and share this with others
above all we always want to challenge
perspectives and promote dialogue among
people so that we can begin and continue
to talk about the issues rather than
hide from them in Sankofa we are bold
with our story we believe it is
important to tell the truth within
context and clarity reminding young
black men and women to tell their truth
writing young black men and women that
they are more than what society says
they are we will all keep - we will all
keep pushing to share Sankofa and to
promote advocacy with pure intentions
above all it is meant to invoke everyone
to think about their position in these
systems of oppression that continue to
infest our country today and to act to
make concrete structural change there is
no one-size-fits-all solution to this
problem but being complacent is not the
answer if you are not fighting to end
the problem you are the problem
[Applause]